[Music]
but i think
what i'm trying to say is i think
there's an x factor with these things
there's this that thing that you just
can't quite
put your finger on sometimes when a
movie goes from being
um just
say die hard
that's a film that's been remade a
million times since but the story is
actually not that
um clever
nobody thought bruce willis could be an
action hero it was made with no money
and nobody in fox wanted to make it in
the end they basically got me it
basically got made because they just
sort of went it's almost like they just
got bored of listening to people moan so
they said oh okay well
um
and they were only like sort of film at
night when no one else was around and
this sort of thing it nearly didn't get
made you know and it's like um
there's a similar story like home alone
which i think is pretty close to the
original you know it's a it's a perfect
movie for what it is
um that's the same thing nearly didn't
get made even these people the
professionals in this is what i'm trying
to say even these people that you know
like making movies is their life
sometimes don't know what a good film is
they can't they you know wouldn't know
if a good film would have slapped him in
the face
theory about um
why um
star wars episodes four five and six
were so much better than one two and
three
well because
you know in episodes four five and six
people still had the courage to tell
george lucas to his face no
yeah especially the editor
but by the time
comes back around to where he can make
first and second and a third
who in hollywood was ever going to tell
george lucas no
yeah
i mean yes mr lucas yes mr lucas jar jar
binks best idea ever mr lucas he's not
at all irritated
i'm not you're taking me sir
bye-bye yeah such a woke-up
bye judger um i have a similar theory
with tim burton
um i think the first batman with michael
keaton is a piece of art i think it is
it is actually pretty close to a perfect
movie but it also then became the
biggest um hit at the time it was you
know number one on the how much money it
made yeah it was you know it made a
phenomenal amount of money when when
some superhero movies weren't making
money
and then tim burton was just allowed to
go they just went well tim burton you're
obviously a genius
you must do whatever you want in the
next movie i love um the idea of a
nightmare after christmas and i remember
before christmas yeah the idea is great
i think it looked great i think it was a
and that film is
but in places it's boring
because of tim burton and his style and
the way he has to make movies and
it's just it just makes you want to hurt
myself um not as bad as watching the
johnny chapter in the chocolate factory
movie makes me want to hurt myself
though that film makes me want to
actually
get your finger off
yeah i'll i'll cut i'll cut whatever you
want off rather than watch that film
burton has a tremendous
fan following i mean he could make
anything and he'd still do great because
he has a tremendous fan following for
that kind of aesthetic in a film
it really is amazing
and it does stand out from anything else
i mean i i i have to argue it's just not
for me i think that's the problem i can
respect
that the style i can respect what he
does it's just not for me just wish
sometimes he had somebody to tone him
back
um like he think i think he did for the
first batman
right just to pull him in a little bit
and i think he would make a better movie
but saying that shouldn't a director do
have free roll isn't that why he's there
i mean it's definitely the director's
piece of art
you know but it's also the studio and
the producer's money
in the studio pay a lot of other people
to have their input that they trust so
it's not
um
[Music]
things don't go awry but there are a few
filmmakers in hollywood that this just
whatever they go whatever they say goes
either whatever the director says go so
like a new hope star wars new hope
episode four
you know the studio got their cut
and then how many cuts did george lucas
produce
yeah you know over and over and over
and by the time we got the episode for
one
no one i mean they knew it was
regardless of how good or bad the movie
was going to be how questionable jar jar
binks would have been
nothing's going to make a ton of cash
yeah where was steven spielberg who was
going to run roughshod over spielberg
probably the one of the best
cinema makers
in the last hundred years i think every
generation sometimes has like the the
you know like in sport every generation
has that like the roger federer you know
or
the the jordan or the michael jordan or
the things like this um
i would say james gunn would be
one of the generations
yeah
he just made some great movies love god
i mean you know peacemaker right um also
guardians of the galaxy yeah
you know you say kevin fey is sort of
he's the he's the like probably the most
powerful man in cinema right now i mean
he did such a good job with the marvel
that basically disney handed him the
company and and not quite you know to me
um right and now he that he can do the
wrong but he's not really a movie maker
he's a manager
you know he's not a director he's not a
writer he's not i think he's he's a
manager he's really great at
he's they've well they've got a formula
and we're sticking to this formula and
then he gets the right people in to do
it's like he's like a great football
manager i'm not sure who the the
who the big players are now that you
think
they can do no wrong well we never know
what is it
we really never know the big players
until a decades past
i mean you know when gremlins came out
well
this little stephen spielberg guy if he
really works hard at it he may make
something of himself
and uh and it was that way
that's next try to lose what an idiot
i mean you know when lucas came out with
thx is like what the hell is that
you know and then you know then there
was like no one i mean then he did
american graffiti and that did very well
and then he got to star wars and what is
this [ __ ] oh god let's yeah just let's
try to kill this in the bathtub if we
can
never exactly happen and then you know
we never know
these are the emerging arctics until
decades pass and they've shaped culture
in ways we've never really expected
so you know it's like um
john favreau you know
so far yeah
um chris nolan has just been suggested
um yeah i mean you could say definitely
a decade ago he was the man he could do
no wrong um like you know david fincher
you know he did the disaster of aliens
three with extreme
uh studio
meddling
yeah and then his next i think his next
film was the game
which was
yeah awesome awesome films awesome
the one thing that you liked by steven
spielberg was he used to make films like
hook
to pay for films like schindler's list
yeah and he was always doing that sort
of those sort of deals with studios i
will make this movie for you that's a
steaming pile of crap
i don't want to make but i want to make
uh the thingity tibet whatever it's
called it's like you know so you fund
that and i'll make you a crapload of
money if you do this and the witch won't
but you might win an oscar that was one
of the things that spielberg goes to
love and i don't see a great deal of
that now it seems to be just like
how do we make money
[Music]